welcome everyone
so uh today this is lecture 21 of
cs229 and the topic for today was
evaluation metrics and also some some
general advice on
applying machine learning in in in
practice you know in deployment or in
production
so we're going to look at a few
evaluation metrics
and next once we're through with this
presentation we'll you know
quickly go through some some some ways
in which these evaluation metrics can
actually be useful in in
production so let's get started
so uh this is the uh quick overview of
what we're going to
be covering in this presentation you
know first you know y evaluation metrics
then
we'll focus on binary classifiers that
will be
that will be the the
problem setting that we'll spend most
time on
uh different kinds of metrics and you
know some general uh tips on how to
choose
evaluation metrics and what to do when
you know uh in certain scenarios when
there's class
imbalance and how certain metrics kind
of break down in
in in different settings
so first of all uh why are uh evaluation
metrics important
in what we have seen in um in all the
algorithms we in in this class we define
some kind of a loss function
and minimize the loss function
with respect to you know the parameters
ah to to minimize the loss on the
training data however these
loss functions it's not always clear
whether these loss functions are
meaningful
in terms of the real world use right
for example the loss function may not
may or may not capture some kind of a
business goal you have
right uh so you know if if your business
goal is to
improve your revenue or your profit like
your loss function may or may not always
reflect that
right so it's always important you know
that that's that's why evaluation
metrics which are like this
this uh secondary uh measure that you
have on your model performance become
extremely important
right it also evaluation metrics also
helps organize your
team effort uh towards some kind of a
business target
right so um usually it's it's common
practice to define some kind of a dev
set
and the team which is working on
improving the model performance
strive to improve the evaluation metric
on that dev set
right uh you you know um
you want you want to start thinking
about the evaluation metric as something
distinct from
the loss itself right and
it's also uh useful to kind of quantify
the gap
between the desired performance
and the baseline right so it's easy for
say a product manager to define what the
evaluation metric should evaluate
to on your dev site but it's hard for
someone to to say
what the loss value should be on a dev
set right so
so evaluation metrics are useful to you
know measure how well your model is
doing in terms of your
desired performance level right so it's
it's useful to
quantify to quantify that gap and uh it
also um you know you can use it to
to see the gap between the desired
performance and the baseline
baseline is generally the first attempt
that you come up with some kind of a
simple model
that gives you a sense of difficulty of
the overall
project that you're starting with if the
gap between the desired performance and
the baseline is a lot then you know
probably it's it's a
a challenging task and similarly you can
also measure the gap between the desired
performance and the current performance
which kind of gives you a sense of how
much more progress is left to be made
right um and it it's also useful to kind
of
keep keep track of how our performance
is improving over time
um you know when we started off we were
at you know 60
accuracy three months in we are at 75
accuracy our ideal
you know our target is you know 85
accuracy so that you know it gives you a
sense of how much
progress you've made towards the end
goal um
it's also useful for lower level tasks
such as debugging right
yes you want to do some bias variance
analysis on your model to improve your
model performance
and evaluation metrics are useful there
as well
so ideally your training objective your
loss function
should reflect your business goal right
but that's not always possible for
example
if you care about accuracy it's very
hard to train a model
by using accuracy as the loss function
right so accuracy is
is um is not even differentiable it's uh
it it ends up being
a very hard combinatorial problem and
it's
using accuracy as your loss loss value
as your loss function
you know generally just does not work
you can't get gradients out of them etc
right so um ideally we would want uh
your metric to itself be the last
function but that's that's not always
feasible
so you know that kind of makes it
necessary to to do this
measuring this evaluation metric in
parallel as we are developing the model
beyond just the loss function
so um we're going to limit uh for most
of this
presentation we're going to stick to
binary classification
uh in a supervised setting so think of x
as an input
x could be an image it could be an email
why is a binary output
you know if it's an image you know you
want to tell whether
there is a pedestrian in that picture or
not uh if you're you know
in the context of say a self-driving car
it could be whether a given text a spam
or not
so why is think of y is binary the model
output is y
hat right and this y hat can be of
different types for certain kinds of
algorithms
for example we did not cover these in in
the course itself but you know
algorithms like k nearest neighbor or
decision trees
the output of the algorithm is directly
the class prediction itself the output
is the class
directly right and there are other kinds
of algorithms
whose output is some kind of a real
valued score like you know support
vector machines or logistic regression
in logistic regression the output was
the probability
of y being one right it's a real value
it's not a class directly
right and with with support vector
machines
uh you would output the margin right how
far from the margin
separating hyperplane is the uh example
that we are looking at either to the to
the left of the margin or to the right
of the margin
right so and those are those are real
values and
in these um these these score based
algorithms where we output some kind of
a real value it's
it becomes necessary to choose some kind
of a threshold
and once you pick that threshold you can
convert your your model into a
classifier
right and these this is uh these core
based uh models are the one we'll be
uh we'll be uh looking at in in this
presentation
right so think of um this is kind of the
mental picture you want to have so uh
the line here from
uh 0 to 1 think of it as
probably the range of probabilities that
can be output by the model
right 0 indicates the predicted
probability is 0 and 1 indicates
predicted probability is 1.
so the the green dots
represent positive examples
and the position of the dot is the
probability assigned by the model for
that example
right so the green dots are are the
positive examples gray dots are the
negative examples and
we we this this by uh placing them on a
line like this we are kind of defining a
natural order on the predictions
right and it's um
it's it's always good to first have a
look at
um you know have a look at this kind of
rank order of your of your examples in
your dev set
before you start debugging your model
right this gives you a you know
a good sense of of uh you know what what
your modulus is kind of doing uh in a
big picture
a few more uh uh you know some metrics
that are
or some terminology that are are useful
so prevalence
is a term that refers to the fraction of
examples that are positives
right so that's that's a standard
terminology so if you're in a situation
where
where you have an equal number of
positive and negative examples
in your data then the prevalence is 50
right if you have
say 10 positive examples and
um and and 90 negative examples then
your prevalence is
10 10 over 10 plus 90.
all right
good question so prevalence uh the
question is is prevalence
a property of the data or is it a
property of the uh of the model
prevalence is totally a property of the
data that you have
um you know you're you're um yeah it's
it's just a fraction of positives that
you
uh so here uh a good good uh uh good
point is that here
when we are counting positives and
negatives we are counting the the true
ground truths not the
predicted probabilities
any questions on this
and then it's this pro this uh
prevalence term that
that allows us to uh kind of uh
decide whether we have something like a
class imbalance problem so a class
imbalance problem is when
you know one of the uh classes is either
too many or
or too little compare relative to the
other class if if
out of 100 examples in your data set if
two are positive and 98 are negative
then you know you generally call it a
class imbalance problem
there's no well uh
well uh agreed upon threshold to decide
whether you have a class imbalance
problem or not
but as a thumb rule if if you know one
of the classes if the prevalence is
you know less than 5 or 10 or more than
or 95 percent then you know it's
reasonable to think of
think of the problem as having low
prevalence
and sometimes for example if um you're
in you're in
uh the problem of say detecting you know
credit card fraud right the volume of
non-fraud transactions is you know is
probably so high that
you know in those kind of problems
prevalence will be really really small
like you know much smaller than one
percent
so we started with uh you know the score
based view i'm going to
go back to the slide to compare again so
we started with this line
where you know we've placed all the
examples
based on by ranking them based on the
predicted probability of the model right
so the green and white are
property of the data their positions is
the property of the model the model
assigned probabilities
for each example and that's how we
sorted it
and this by itself is not a classifier
but once we decide a threshold
right once we have a threshold let's say
we set the threshold equals 0.5
now we have a classifier every every
example that's above the threshold line
is classified as positive whether it was
positive or not
every every example below the threshold
is classified as negative
right so the the uh vertical axis
is uh is is our prediction
anything above the uh the 0.5 threshold
is predicted to be positive
anything below is predicted to be
negative and the
true label is on this um
you know we we kind of separate them
horizontally so to the left
is those examples that truly are
positive and to the right
are examples that truly are negative
right um and here we've chosen uh our
threshold to be you know
arbitrarily 0.5 and
only once we choose a threshold
does ah score based model become a
classifier until we decide a threshold
it's not a classifier right
it's just assigning scores or
probabilities after we choose a
threshold we get a classifier
right so uh what did we do here
we just summed up the number of examples
in each block
right so on the on the uh top left is
the examples that were actually
positive and we also predicted positive
and similarly
on the on the right right top we have
examples
that were predicted positive but were
actually negative right
and this kind of a matrix is called a
confusion matrix
and that's just a standard terminology
right so a few properties of
uh of of the confusion matrix
the first is that the total sum of all
the
uh all the four squares is fixed
right because the number of examples we
have is fixed right
also the column sums are also fixed
right the sum 9 plus 1 and 2 plus 8 in
this case will always be fixed because
they they are you know the number of
positive examples we have and number of
uh negative
examples we have what can change in
confusion matrix
is the uh based on what threshold we
choose
and the way in which the examples have
been
have been ordered by our model
the the fraction of the left column that
goes up and below and fraction of the
right column that gets split up and
below that can change
right so the total sum mistakes the the
column sums are also fixed right
and basically by looking at a confusion
matrix
you kind of judge the quality of your
model
depending on how heavy the diagonals are
and how
light the off diagonals are right so you
want the diagonals to be heavy
which means you want the the uh examples
that were positive to be predicted
positive and that were negative to be
predicted negative
and you want the errors you know you
know
examples that were positive or predicted
negative to be low and you know
similarly that were negative and
predicted positive to be low
so another observation to make here is
that a confusion matrix does not give
you a scalar value like it's a set of
four numbers
right given two uh different confusion
matrix
matrices for the same model in the same
data set
it's hard to it's hard to compare them
and say which confusion matrix is better
right they're not scalars they're like
sets of four numbers
you can't compare them um unambiguously
and and so we start
extracting comparable uh metrics out of
this
so the uh top left that the the the
number in the in the top left quadrant
is called true positives so they are uh
true positives
uh is a confusing
term so you you might want to you know
it's it's
uh true positive sounds like what what
is the ground truth but but
unfortunately the term true positive
refers to
examples that were actually positive and
were also predicted to be positive
right so in this case true positive is
uh is is 9 right and so
on on the on the uh right hand side
we're going to start extracting
these metrics or statistics out of this
confusion matrix
next true negatives you know again true
negatives ah
is the number of examples that were
actually negative but also predicted to
be
negative uh here trueness refers to you
know
um you know that our prediction was true
that's that's what it basically means so
true positive means
it was predicted positive and we got it
right true negative means it was
actually negative and we got it right
right so so trueness kind of lies on the
diagonal
we want the true positives and true
negatives to be high
right so false positive
is examples
that were predicted to be positive
but our prediction was wrong a false
prediction so false positives are
examples that were actually negative but
we predicted them as positive
and ah similarly false negative are
um examples that were
actually positive but we predicted them
as a negative
and these two are are false positives
and false negatives
are are kind of you know two very
different kinds of errors and depending
on the
actual application that you are working
on
uh false positives and false negatives
may have very different kinds of impacts
right it's it's uh very common that
the the uh the kind of weight that you
want to assign to false positives and
false negatives
will generally be asymmetric
um so um so we have you know basically
extracted four metrics out of this
confusion metric so far
and this false positive and false
negative are
um they also have uh some other
terminology for example
they're also called type one and type
two errors right so
type one error is when um is a false
positive
when you know you don't have a certain
condition but you predict that you have
the condition you don't have
you know the the the y label is false
but you predicted y to be true right
similarly the type two error
uh is is commonly called um uh is
another name for false negatives
where the the true uh uh condition is
is true is uh is one
you know y equals one but you predict y
equals zero right
uh this is um um you know i found this
on
on on twitter on um on on someone's uh
uh twitter page but i
could not find the source of um
source of the image to to cite it but
you know it's it's
it's a funny image right
so um so so uh
back to back to the slide the larger
take away is that
depending on the kind of errors you make
the
the kind of impact that false positives
and false negatives have
can be very very different right so if
you were to for example prescribe some
kind of
a medication uh then you know uh
false positives and false negatives can
have different kinds of effects you know
depending on whether the uh so for
example if you want to prescribe a
medication based on whether a person has
a disease or not
and if that medication has no adverse
side effects
when given to an ordinary person then
you are
much more likely to worry about false
false negatives because you don't want
to lose out on
people from getting that medication so
you want all the
people who have the patients who have
the condition to be predicted so that
you can give the medication
um
right so um another metric is accuracy
right so accuracy is basically what is
the
fraction of all the examples no matter
what class they were
that we predicted right that we got them
right right so accuracy is generally
you know kind of the trace of the matrix
divided by you know
the sum of all the elements and if you
want to
optimize your model for accuracy then
it corresponds to actually using
something that's called the zero one
loss
right zero one loss refers to you know
um
you have a loss of one if you got the
answer uh uh
correct and um you get you get zero if
you got it wrong right so optimizing for
zero one loss
which is very hard to do in practice
because it's not a differentiable loss
is is um that's accuracy
right now we um there is
another metric that's very important
called precision
right so accuracy and precision in our
day-to-day language we we might kind of
use them interchangeably uh whether we
are accurate or precise
but um in in a statistical setting or in
a machine learning setting the two have
very very different meanings
right so accuracy is what fraction of
all the examples that we got to write
whether they were
um whether they were they were you know
positives or negatives doesn't matter
whether we
predicted them right or not that's what
accuracy measures
however precision means among the
examples that we predicted to be
positive
what fraction of them were actually
right so in precision we are kind of
limited to the top half of the confusion
matrix
right so the top half of the confusion
is characterizing all the examples that
were predicted to be positive
and now precision measures what fraction
of
the predicted examples were actually
positive right and there's another name
for precision it's also called ppv
so ppv stands for positive predicted
value
so precision is also called ppv
positive
predictive value
right yes
yeah so the question is uh if you if you
uh worry a lot about false positives you
know how do you kind of quantify that
into you into your loss function uh
because your last function is just a
loss function
uh we'll touch upon that in in some of
the future slides
but but that's that's a good question
that's that's the kind of questions you
should be thinking about because
our last function is is you know uh is
uh you know is our loss function kind of
asymmetrically treating
uh false positive or false negatives uh
if not should it how do we do it you
know
that's that's definitely a a very good
question right
so uh that's precision so precision is
among the examples that we predicted to
be positive you know what what fraction
of them were actually positive
and um you know um you can you can see
that you know
the the uh precision is uh all these
metrics
uh that we've seen so far you know true
positive true negative false positive
false negative accuracy precision
all these are all metrics that actually
depend on the threshold that we choose
right uh so these are all threshold uh
sensitive metrics
right similarly there is uh something
called sensitivity
sensitivity is also called recall right
so precision
recall is also called sensitivity
so in recall the ah what recall measures
is
if we were to use this classifier in in
uh
in deployment what fraction of all the
actual positives are we going to recover
right so if if uh um
we we let's say there are you know uh
100 patients who are
out there and some fraction of them say
half of them have a certain condition
we run all the patients through our
model and our model is going to predict
you know true or
you know predict positive or negative
for each example or each patient
and finally if we um if if we
look at all the patients who actually
had the condition what fraction of those
patients
did our model predict as as a positive
right
and this is called sensitivity so this
the the term sensitivity kind of uh
comes from i think it comes from
epidemiology where you know how
sensitive
is this test for detecting a certain
condition right that's that's exactly
what this is measuring
so um in this case say uh there were a
total of ten
uh positive exact positive examples i'm
counting uh
the the examples on the left half of the
confusion matrix
and sensitivity is measuring you know
the top number
nine divided by nine plus one so like
you know so the sensitivity here is
is ninety percent because we were able
to correctly
um or we were able to recover 9 out of
the
10 positive positive examples
so one thing to to note here
is that sensitivity is kind of
staying agnostic to everything on the
right right so we are only focused on
what fraction of patients were
or what fraction of examples that were
actually positive so we are conditioning
on just the positive examples and
checking you know what fraction of them
we were able to recover
right this is this is completely
agnostic to
what happened to the examples that were
that had a ground truth of negative we
we're just ignoring that
that that half of uh our data set
completely
right so um
the the um one one one way to another uh
uh way to think of this is
if you want to have perfect recall
right if you want to have 100 recall
then
no matter how good or bad your model is
just choose a threshold of
of zero right if you choose a threshold
of zero no matter how good or bad your
model is you will get hundred percent
recall
right and similarly if you want to in in
the previous example over here
uh this was about precision if you want
to have a model
that is hundred 100 precise right
then all that you want to do is uh
choose the threshold
such that uh choose a threshold such
that the threshold
just classifies the top one example to
be positive
and you will get 100 percent recall
right so
viewing these metrics in isolation
generally does not
kind of capture the the true performance
of a model
right so ah
so so uh to to um
so what we'll we will see the shortly
that most of the times you are trying to
balance off
you know precision and recall in some
way because we don't want
we don't want our metric to be you know
blindly placed all the way
at the bottom to maximize our recall
similarly we don't want our
threshold to be blindly placed all the
way at the top to just get good
uh precision number yes question
so the question is you know why are we
looking at the top half
we are interested in the left half yeah
so the left half of this matrix
are you know the the examples that have
a ground truth to be positive
right but our model when it's making a
prediction it does not know
you know what what uh what the ground
truth is and it's going to assign some
kind of a probability
and depending on what threshold we
choose right so in this case threshold
was 0.5
you know we classify everything that the
model classified
you know as above above 0.5 to be
we predict them to be positive right we
don't know what the ground truth is yes
we are interested in the left half
but the only way we can classify them is
as you know top half and bottom half
good question so that's that's uh recall
similarly there's something called
negative recall so negative recall
is uh basically doing the same
same exercise as as a recall but we do
it on the on the right hand side of
of this of the confusion matrix which
means so negative recall
is is uh is is is calculating
of all the examples that had a a true or
the actual label to be negative what
fraction of that sub population
did the model actually class correctly
classify as negative
right and in negative recall uh just
like
a a positive recall we kind of stay
agnostic to the left half
of this picture right we don't we don't
uh we don't
we don't care how correctly or
incorrectly the model performed on the
uh on the ground truth uh uh equals
positive
we just look at consider the examples on
the right hand uh right hand side and
and see what fraction of the
uh actual examples uh actual negative
examples to the model correct
correctly classifiers are negative
and negative recall has another term
specificity
right so negative we call this r
and you can start um kind of combining
these individual scores uh into you know
um
in in in certain ways for example
there's something called the f score or
the f1 f1 score
so f1 score is uh you can you can uh so
f1
score is basically the uh
f1 score is the harmonic mean of of uh
precision and recall so one over f1 is
one over precision plus one over recall
right so you can combine your precision
and recall into a single number called
the
ah f1 score
similarly there is ah something called
just like the f score there is something
called
the g-score which is the geometric mean
of
of precision and recall so
so the g-score
you have r so uh
the geometric means so it is you know
log g equals
log precision plus
log recall so it's it's uh or you know g
is square root of precision
times recall and ah f square
f f square is therefore you know
precision times
recall over precision
plus recall
oh sorry
no it's not square obviously sorry so uh
so g well so g is ah so ignore this g
is actually so this is the correct
it is the geometric mean um so i i guess
i i missed a half over there yeah
yes question
what's happening yeah so you know what
what do these
f scores and g scores kind of represent
so
as we saw before um
just looking at precision or just
looking at recall uh
is is insufficient because you can just
fool the model by having 100 recall by
setting the threshold all the way to
zero
right but if you were to do that you
will take a hit on precision
right and similarly if you if you if you
maximize your precision to 100 by
setting your threshold all the way at
the top
so that you just classify that one
correct example is positive
and and just ignore everything else the
precision will be
100 but your recall will be really low
because you've recovered only one out of
all the uh
positive examples that you have right so
it is some way to kind of
balance the two in some way so you know
uh
these the the geometric mean and and
harmonic mean are
um are are uh you know kinds of means
where if any one of them is low then
the entire mean is low which is not the
case with arithmetic means
arithmetic mean will just is is uh it's
pretty robust to stay high but geometric
mean will
will just uh bring down your uh value to
be really low if either one of them is
is low so these are just two different
you know two different ways of kind of
combining the two the two metrics in
some way
yeah it's it's another way to to um to
say you know what is the min of my
precision and recall right
that's what the geometric mean is kind
of doing undercover this question
why aren't we just maximizing accuracy
so the question is why not just focus on
accuracy why are we doing all the all
these other things we'll come to that
so so so so the question is does
accuracy capture precision and recall in
some way
[Music]
maybe maybe not we'll see we'll see more
more you know why
accuracy is is not always the right
thing to
look for right so in in
examples when in in situations where
your data is well balanced you have
an equal number of positives and
negatives then you know accuracy and
prison and recall will be more or less
kind of
similar uh but if if you have class
imbalance
let's say you know just one percent of
all your
examples are positive right and 99 of
your examples are negative
then if you have a model that just says
no to everything it'll get 99
accuracy right so so in
in class imbalance situations these
precision and recall kind of metrics
are will be much more robust uh from you
know
from from getting fooled whereas
accuracy can be easily fooled in
low impala low prevalence scenarios
right so that's that's f score
uh and now so uh everything that we've
seen so far
are specific to this chosen threshold
right so our model did the ranking
and then we chose a threshold and out of
this once we once we chose this
threshold
we got this confusion matrix and from
the confusion matrix we extracted all
these
threshold specific metrics
now what happens if we change the
threshold from 0.5
let's say we move it up to 0.6
right if we were to choose a different
threshold then
you know some of these numbers changed
so uh the
um the metrics that change are
highlighted in red so i'm gonna
go back one slide for you to compare
again right so this was with um
with threshold equals 0.5 with 0.6 we
see that the true positive change the
true negative did not change
similarly the false negative change the
accuracy changed the specificity did not
change you know
so some of them changed some of them did
not change right
and now now um you know
similarly we can we can um repeat this
exercise
by trying you know trying as many
different thresholds as possible
so first of all how many effective
thresholds are in this
uh are are there in this situation for
example
you know choosing the threshold uh
here versus slightly below changes
nothing
right no example was was a
classification of
no example um are changed so in in this
kind of
a situation the number of effective
thresholds we have
is one plus the number of examples
right so uh that gives us all all the
possible
uh different thresholds that are
somewhat meaningful
and so what we can do is basically um
repeat this exercise of not just
checking at you know 0.5 or 0.6 but
check it with all possible thresholds
so this is the same ranking right the
ranking has not changed
ranking is a property of the model but
the threshold is something that we
choose to apply
after the fact right and for each
particular value of the threshold
corresponds to
each row in the stable on the right side
right and as we
as we change the threshold we get
different values of
you know true positive true negative
accuracy percent recall and so on right
now ah as i said each row corresponds to
each
effective threshold and the table itself
is a property of our model so if our
model was were if
we were to take a different model and
you know take the predictions from the
other model
the ranking would probably be very
different
right and ah and and so this this entire
table is kind of
specific to the model that made the
predictions but each rows within this
table
depends on what threshold that we chose
and you can make a few more observations
in in
in this table so first of all many of
these columns
are monotonic so for example true
positives
starts at zero and monotonically
increases to ten
true negative you know similarly
monotonically decreases
uh similarly false positive
monotonically increases false negative
monotonically decreases
ah recall monotonically increases starts
at zero and
ends at one and specificity
monotonically decreases starts at one
and ends at zero
however there are um these other
uh metrics for example f1 score right
there there is there's no
um strict ordering it kind of reaches a
maximum somewhere at around
a threshold of you know 0.4 or something
similarly accuracy accuracy also kind of
reaches a maximum at
0.45 and it it it reduces as we go to
the extremes
right so some of them have this this
kind of
monotonic relation where you know we
increase in one direction or decrease in
the other direction
and precision is kind of
interesting because in in precision
we kind of keep going up and down right
so precision
uh we start at one come down to point
six go up to point seven five point
eight point eight three and then come
down to point seven one
so it's kind of it's kind of you know
going up and down
and so what we want to do is
try to capture the trade-off between
these columns in some way
right so as we saw before if you want to
just maximize recall
just just set your threshold to zero if
you want to
uh maximize your precision maybe just
set it at
at one or just below one but instead
what we want to do is
not just look at how the model performs
at some
specified threshold but summarize this
these these entire columns in some way
right and so that's that's the question
how do we summarize the trade-off
between say
precision and recall or specificity and
sensitivity
right and that's where things like the
roc curves come into picture
right in the roc curve uh it's called
the receiver operator characteristic
curve
it is a trade-off between specificity
and sensitivity
right so sometimes you may see the roc
curve to be
flipped in some books you know or some
some articles
you'll see it flipped where on the on
the x-axis you have one minus
sensitivity you know
there but it's it's basically the same
right and so the roc curve is this
uh is the plot that you get by scanning
the threshold
so i'm going to go back one slide so
two slice rather so as we scan the
threshold
from zero to one and for each threshold
we read off the sensitivity and
specificity
and plot that point on a graph of
sensitivity versus specificity and as we
plot the different points by
that we get by scanning different
thresholds you know connect those points
as well
and you get this roc curve right so the
roc curve is uh
is giving you the trade-off between
sensitivity and specificity as we scan
the threshold
so for example when the threshold is um
is is uh set at 1.0
so you know you set the threshold all
the way at the top right your recall
will be zero
right your sensitivity will be
your sensitive your specif
when when you when you um set your
threshold all the way at the top
at one that corresponds to the top left
uh
uh top left corner your sensitivity will
be zero
but specificity will be you know uh will
be maximum
and as you keep bri you know
bring as you keep scanning your
threshold uh
down towards zero you start exploring
these all these other points
right so one way to think of the
the roc curve uh is
so another way to to think of it is
let me use
so create a grid
right create a grid where ah you have
you you chop up the horizontal axis
into equal sized uh ranges
into as many number of examples you have
so if you have
say 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12. so let's
say you have
12 positive examples
right and chop up the vertical axis into
the number of negative examples that you
have so 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13. so
13 negative examples
examples right and now your model gives
you
you know some kind of an ordering right
so your ordering looks something like
this right so
positive positive
negative positive
and so on so it is going to give you
some some kind of an ordering now
one way to think of this roc curve is
start from the top left right
and inspect one example at a time
right if you encounter a
positive examples move right
if you encounter a negative example move
down
right so first is a positive we move
right another is a positive
we move right next we got an ex a
negative example we move down
then we got a positive move right
positive move right etcetera
and because we have uh uh we can only
make
you know 12 number of you know exactly
12 number of right moves and 13 number
of down moves
no matter what order you are you always
start here and you always end here
right and if all your positive examples
are
at the top then your curve will
will look like this so it will it will
tend towards the top right corner if
most of the positive examples are at the
top
right and so this intuition gives rise
to this derived metric from an roc curve
called the area under the roc curve
right so the area under the roc curve is
basically this area
and this area under the roc curve will
be high
if most of the positive examples or if
all of the positive examples
are the ones you encounter first as you
start scanning down
right because you know positive example
will just keep you
moving to the right and another
observation you can you can you can
make is that roc curves always have this
you know can always be broken down into
these
horizontal and vertical segments or
chunks
and each each chunk corresponds to
you know one segment of
consecutively occurring positive group
or a negative group
right so you keep moving to the right so
you get you get one long horizontal
chunk if you have a lot you if you
encounter lots of positive examples
and then once you once you switch over
to you know some negative examples you
kind of get a kink here and you start
moving down
and so on right so this is this is uh
the roc curve
and the area under the roc curve is
generally a useful metric
to to uh to check how well our model is
is kind of
classifying right if if it does a good
job of placing all the positives up and
negatives down then
the area under the roc curve will be
high
any questions on this
cool so a few
a few more observations on roc curves so
if you have a model that randomly
assigns
probabilities to your examples then the
roc curve
will follow along this diagonal right so
if you if let's say you you you have a
model
you get an example and your
your model instead of you know
predicting some kind of a probability
it just samples a probability between
zero and one
in the uniform distribution zero one and
outputs that ah probability then the roc
curve
will will will exactly uh coincide with
this diagonal
line of course uh you know this diagonal
line looks
smooth you know it assumes you have lots
and lots of examples
otherwise it's going to be you know a
diagonal line that you know looks like
this
right so your your uh a random guesser
will have an roc of 0.5
right so so that's like a low bar
for what you should be aiming for with
roc right
if your if your a model has an roc less
than 0.5
then your model is basically doing worse
than random guessing right that's bad
however you know there is there is um
if it is if it is doing like really low
like if your
model has an roc of 0.1 that is somewhat
good news because you can just flip the
labels
and you can get a really high roc right
so um
stay staying at 0.5 if your rrc is 0.5
that's bad
uh you want it to be as high as possible
but if it's really low
you can always just flip the labels and
you know it will perform
perform pretty well but of course that
is still disturbing you should you know
definitely investigate why it is
predicting low maybe there's a bug
somewhere
but you know uh yeah so so so 0.5 is
is is it should be the low bar when
you're
looking at roc values so if you see um
if you see you know read some paper and
say the roc was you know 0.65
you know uh you should not think of the
model could have scored 0 to 1
and achieved 0.65 you should think of
you know between you know c point six
five as the ratio starting from point
five to one not from starting from zero
to one
right
so something with an roc of point six is
quite close to
random guessing
there's another interpretation of the rs
the area under the roc curve
so the other interpretation of the area
under the roc curve is supposing
um you choose
a random example a random positive
example
and then separately you choose a random
negative example
now what is the probability that this
in this random pair of positive and
negative examples
the positive examples will be ranked
higher than the
negative example that probability
is exactly equal to the area under the
rfc curve right so that's that's another
way to think of the roc
what's the what's the probability that a
random positive example
is ranked higher than a random negative
example
rank means um in this you know uh
if you pick one random positive example
say it was you know this green dot pick
another random
negative example say it was this gray
dot right
those random positive and negative
examples get some kind of a score from
the model
were those scores ordered in the correct
way
that's what roc measures
any any questions
so another thing to note is that the roc
curve
is agnostic to the prevalence of your
data set
right so what that means is if
instead of 13 examples you had 130
examples
right all that means is the granularity
of
each of the vertical drop would be
smaller
right but roughly speaking you will
still get a similar
area under the curve right it
it it would just be a little more fine
grained
but the area under the curve will be
pretty much the same so the auroc
is agnostic to the prevalence of of the
data set
that's that's uh that's something to you
know keep in mind when you're evaluating
models
uh because that's both the strength and
the weakness of the roc
roc curve that the roc curve um
if if if you measured your um if the roc
curve that is reported to you was
measured on
a data set that had equal prevalence but
let's say in the real world
the the the true prevalence is is very
different
um then you know that the roc per the
roc performance on the real world will
still be the same
so that's a good part of it but the bad
part of it is probably the roc curve
is measuring the wrong thing right uh if
if it is if it is
um if it's if the if what it reports is
agnostic to the uh
to the prevalence then maybe what what
roc is measuring is
is not the right metric and we will see
some of that
soon all right so
that's roc curves so there's this
so the roc curve was was the trade-off
between
sensitivity and specificity the
precision recall curve
is uh you know is the trade-off between
precision and recall right uh it's
it's uh plotted in the same uh in a
similar way as the roc curve
right you start with the threshold at
point one
read off the precision and the recall
values
you know you get up you get a point and
then you know scan down the threshold a
little bit
read the new precision and recall values
that's the next point you know connect
it by a line
next bring down the threshold some more
you get a new percentage
value plot it and connect by line and
finally you get
a full curve that looks like this right
and this is called the precision recall
curve
a few things to note here again the
the roc curve was kind of monotonic
in the sense it could never go back up
right you would it would either go to
the right or come down
to the right or come down it could never
go back up whereas the precision recall
curve
can sometimes go back up and the reason
for that is
in what we are measuring is
a trade-off between precision and recall
so let's imagine what happens if we were
to
start over here right bring the
threshold down we got one example
and that one example was positive so the
precision
is a hundred percent but the recall was
you know point one so by by uh we come
to this point basically where the
precision
is you know a hundred percent but the
recall is point one then let's say
we bring the threshold down one more
level
the thresh the precision is still at 100
the recall has increased to you know
0.2 because we recovered 2 out of the 10
examples
and then let's say we encountered a
third example a third that was negative
right so the recall has not improved at
all because we've still recovered only 2
out of the 10 example but the precision
drops from
2 out of two to two out of three right
so
the drops are always vertical because we
come down in precision
but whenever we encounter a new example
the precision will come down but the
recall will stay the same
because the number of positive examples
that we've recovered is you know does
not does not change
if we encounter a new negative example
so the precision recall curve
has these vertical drops that correspond
to encountering negative examples
in our scan right but once we are here
lets lets say we start encountering
positive examples again
then then what we see is
so we go from 2 out of three
to three out of four to four out of five
so this is like a gradual increase as we
encounter more positive examples
so the precision recall curve will um
will have these you know pretty a pretty
standard pattern of having vertical
drops
and slow climbs vertical drops and slow
climbs
whereas the roc curve will have
horizontal
vertical horizontal vertical movements
and
just like the roc curve you can you can
also measure the area under the
precision recall curve
right and one one kind of ah
another observation that you can make is
that while the roc curve always started
at the top left corner and ended at the
bottom right corner
the precision recall curve when it
reaches 100 percent
recall right when you when when you take
the the threshold
all the way to zero your precision
when you you effectively you know
predicted
everything to be positive your precision
will be exactly equal to your prevalence
right so the precision recall curve will
terminate at at the at the right hand
side
at the level equal to the prevalence so
in this case prevalence was
you know 0.5 ish or yeah somewhere
somewhere there
right so it ends here at our prevalence
equals 0.5
that also means that you know there is
this
the precision recall curve
you know might look something like like
this
so this is always the prevalence level
where the precision recall curve will
end
it also means that there is this
kind of area in a precision recall curve
a certain area in the curve where the
precision recall curve just cannot enter
right no matter how horribly you
you your model ranks your examples
in the worst case let's say your model
places all the negatives at the top
and all the positives at the bottom like
the worst possible situation
right in the worst possible situation
you're going to keep encountering
negatives that's going to you know kill
our precision
with zero recall right and
we're going to start off climbing the
roc
the precision recall curve starting from
the first positive example
and we are going to basically start at
uh you know
once the threshold comes here we are
going to start at 1 over
the sum of you know all the negative
examples
plus 1 from that we are going to move on
to
2 over sum of all the negative examples
plus 2 and so on until we reach
a number of positive over
number of negative plus
number of positive and it's going to be
the slow climb
until the prevalence level so no matter
how bad your
model is you know you you kind of get
this amount of area for free
in the area under the precision recall
right so
ah there is there is uh there are
variants of the area under the precision
curve
that account for this that kind of you
know discounts this area and only
measures
you know kind of the area that your mod
has truly earned and you know
regarding disregarding the part you get
for free
um and that's something uh you might be
might be kind of um
that's something worth knowing right if
your prevalence is very high then your
area under precision recall curve might
look very good just because you get
a lot of area just for free
all right moving on okay
so let's let's look at these two
these two models right so uh we
it's let's suppose there is some data
set
and we have two models model a and model
b right and the models
models a and b make predictions or
assign probability values to every
example
and let's say we you know um this is the
plot you know
so model a assigned you know some
negative example this
probability value and this probability
value and
these are just the probability values
that were assigned by model a and these
are the
ah probability my values that were
assigned by model b
now by just looking at this is there a
reason to prefer one model over the
other is one of them better than the
other
or does one of them look better than the
b looks better okay anybody thinks a
looks better
why does b look better
so so the the answer was b was
confusing uh for a few points but you
know it did well on this region and it
did well on this region
right yeah so yeah it might be
reasonable to to
think b does does better and we should
we should um
you know choose b now of all the metrics
that we have looked so far
which metric would rank b higher than a
none
any any other guesses
right that's but that's the correct
answer none of them will rank
b higher than a because the ranking of
all the points
were the same right all the points over
here
though they were clustered together the
if you if you just look at the ranking
position of all the examples
we encounter positives and negatives in
the same order
and all the metrics that we've seen so
far only cared about the ranking
right for example for the area under the
precision recall cover we were scanning
the thresholds
but we were only you know making moves
when we encountered the next positive or
negative example
right we didn't we didn't care what the
threshold value was
we just looked at the order in which the
the positives and negatives were
encountered
right so all the all the metrics that we
have seen so far
are ranking based metrics right
and ah as we can see here here are two
situations
which qualitatively look very different
but from the point of view
of all the metrics we have seen so far
they are exactly the same
right and that's that's a kind of a
motivation
for something that is called the log
loss
the log loss is um
it's it's in fact the the loss value
that we use
in logistic regression right so the log
loss is uh
think of the log loss as
so if you remember in logistic
regression if the true label was y
and our prediction was y hat right the
last that we used
was y
log y hat plus 1 minus
y log 1 minus
y hat right this value itself
can be used as a metric
right so it's basically just the the the
the
log likelihood of our prediction that's
also called the log loss
right so the log loss is um
is is kind of different from the two
that we've seen so far
uh is kind of different from the ones uh
that we've seen
seen so far in that it it takes into
account
the value of of the
predicted probability itself it's not
just looking at the
at the uh relative uh thresholds right
so if we were to
kind of sum over i equals 1 to n
no y i y
i y hat i right so this
this loss value takes into account the
predicted value
of the probability as well right and
it basically rewards confident correct
answers
which means it's not enough that you you
know
when you're when you're um when you
predict
a correct answer with a relatively high
probability
then it rewards you to take that even
higher
but at the same time it very heavily
penalizes you when you get it wrong and
are very confident about it
right so it's it's kind of asymmetric in
the in the way that
it rewards you for having confident
correct answers
but pretty much kills you if you make a
confident wrong answer
right and um it is it is uh this this
property
that makes the model kind of choose the
actual probability value
more carefully right ah this this this
objective does not just
uh does not just look at whether you
know the positives were higher and
negatives were low
it also looks into how much uh
you know what level of confidence did
the model assign in each of these
predictions right so another way to
think of the
log loss is you can think of a betting
game
right let's say you need to make a
prediction
of of of n examples let's say there are
n examples
they can be positive or negative and
you're going to be presented one example
at a time
and you need to make a prediction of you
know true or false
and the way you're asked to make this
prediction is not just
you know make a prediction but you're
asked to make a bet
right you need to make a bet of some
dollar amount between zero and one
and say you know 25 cents or 99 cents or
whatever
you need to make a bet of what the
correct answer is for a given example
now if you make the bet you
you you win the the bet amount
but if you lose the bet you win one
minus the better amount
right so ah which means now if uh
um so let's say you know you have
example i
x i you need to make a bet of you know
what is the
well you need to make a bet of what uh
uh uh
of of how confident you are about the
you know um
prediction that you made let's say you
predict it to be you know ah
y equals one you know you make some
prediction and you you also place
a bet we call it p right
and for x x two
let's say you predict y equals whatever
zero and some
bit amount p let's call this p 1
p 2. now if you if you win
you get p if you lose you get 1 minus p
right and then finally you know you go
through all the examples
and in the very end what you get is not
the sum of them
but the product of them
right so for for one example maybe you
got
you got the correct answer and you
earned this value and for another
example maybe you got it wrong and you
earned this value
right and the final uh take home
amount that you're going to that you're
going to
walk away with at the end of it is going
to be the product of all these values
right which means if for any one of the
examples
you predicted you assigned a confidence
of 1
or 0.99999 and you happen to be wrong
the entire product will be zero or very
close to zero
right so so in this exercise um
in fact there are there are kind of uh
studies that show that
you know in with this kind of an
exercise
you can extract the the true level of
confidence that
a person has in making a bet right if
you were to earn the sum of these things
then you would be a lot more
you would you your your betting strategy
would be very different
but if you're going to walk away with
the product of all these values
then you know that if you make one
confident
wrong prediction you assign a
probability of one and the answer was
wrong
then you get zero and the product of
zero with anything else is zero
right and um so that's that's
basically how the uh yeah a question
so the question is can we use this in uh
when
on models that make the class direct
class predictions rather than
scores of probabilities no so the log
log loss is for
probabilistic models only
so the question is you know um
perhaps rightly you're identifying that
you know wouldn't this
encourage the models to be more
conservative you know rather than making
extreme values
yeah the log loss can make your models
more conservative
but uh the
the um the interesting thing out of this
is that
this process you know this kind of a
loss is a
proper scoring rule which means
which means the predicted probabilities
you know from from this kind of a loss
will always result in you know
calibrated probabilities
yeah so the question is uh would this be
a good good metric or good loss to use
say in a financial setting where you
generally take the sum of you know
rewards rather than
yeah so there are there are um um you
know
you know if you if you're interested you
know the the thing to look for are
robust scoring rules
and we're going to look at one in in a
few slides so there are other kind of
scoring rules
which still give you you know calibrated
probabilities other scoring rules that
give you
calibrated probabilities but are much
more risk tolerant
than the log loss right and and you can
use those
uh in those contexts
right so uh so the log loss
is this uh is this kind of a loss that
not only evaluates the quality it not
only evaluates whether you
you you know got the answer right or
wrong but also
kind of elicits the true level of
confidence
or the true kind of belief you have
probabilistic belief you have in making
making a certain uh prediction
so this is this is an example of a
proper scoring rule and we we saw kind
of proper scoring rules in in
the maximum entropy lecture as well
right
so that's log loss which brings us to uh
this concept of calibration
right so calibration is when the
predicted probabilities match
the real world occurrence or frequencies
right so in this case
we have two models on the right over
here right so the blue line
corresponds to the calo is the
calibration curve of
you know a logistic regression model and
the orange line
corresponds to the calibration curve of
a support vector classifier support
vector machine
right what the way to
read this plot is on the x-axis
the x-axis corresponds to predicted
probabilities
and the y-axis is the fraction of
positives
in the region around this predicted
probability
right and the bottom plot over here is
just a histogram
of how were the different predicted
probabilities
how are they distributed right and
you always want to look at a calibration
plot
and the histogram of predicted
probabilities in conjunction all the
time
right so if
the calibration curve goes close to the
45 degree line
it means when the predicted probability
was
0.8 for example then the
actual fraction of examples was also you
know roughly 80 percent
similarly if the of all the predictions
that had a prediction of 0.2 roughly 20
of them were you know the positives
right however the orange curve looks
pretty different right so in for the
orange curve
even when it predicted you know a 0.6
probability most of them were actually
you know most of them were actually you
know
positives this means that the orange
curve you can think of it as being
underconfident in some way and even
though
the examples were mostly positive it
kind of hesitated
to assigning high probabilities to them
right so even even in the region where
you know the predictions are still 0.6
and 0.7
all of them are actually you know
positive examples
right ah so a calibration curve that
looks like this
so a perfectly calibrated curve would be
like a straight line
right an under confident calibration
curve will have this kind of an inverted
s
shape right similarly an over confident
a model will have a calibration curve
that looks like this
right so this would correspond to over
confident
this is under confident
and if it is directly here this is you
know well calibrated
so um the the uh
few takeaways from this slide is that
it's it's always you know important to
kind of see
these two plots in conjunction
and the way you want to read them is
first make sure that your model is well
calibrated
right if your model is not even
calibrated then the probabilities that
it is
predicting are not even valid
probabilities
right and then once you once you know
that a model is well calibrated
then look at the histogram to see if you
have these nice two peaks
at the extremes right so that
that's like the perfect scenario where
the calibration curve is
is exactly along the 45 degree lines and
the
and the histogram it has these two
perfect
uh uh you know two peaks all the way to
the left and another peak all the way to
the right so that's that's the
ideal scenario however
if your model is not well calibrated
right
in this case in the orange case if the
model is not well calibrated
then this histogram says nothing at all
it does not tell you whether the model
is doing well or bad
right in this example if you see you
know both these models
have ah you know for a chosen threshold
of 0.5 the logistic regression and
support vector machine
have you know 0.87 precision 0.85 recall
0.86 f1 score they are all exactly the
same
right but the calibration of the support
vector machine is
completely bonkers you know it's not
well calibrated at all
and so the histogram does not reflect
the quality of classification right but
if the
model is well calibrated then the
histogram gives you a good sense of
so of of how well the model is
separating them
so just like the log loss that we saw
over here there is this
other score that you can use called the
briar score
so the briar score is
very similar to the mean squared error
so the breyer score
you can think of this as sum over i
equals one to n
of all your ah n examples p
hat you know where this is the predicted
probability
right so p hat i minus
y i squared
it's just the mean of the squared error
between the
label and the predicted probability nice
question
so it's if if your model is over
confident
then your histogram will generally look
like the blue one
because it's it's assigning like really
high high uh
uh probabilities so you know the
probabilities are more at the
at the extremes it's it's more confident
but they are wrong which means
they've got the orderings strongs so
over here in the histogram
that you know the labels are not visible
here
right so this means most of the
probabilities
most of the examples got this probably
but it does not tell you what fraction
of them were
correct or wrong right whereas the the
uh
calibration curve tells you what
fraction of them were correct or wrong
it could look similar to so yeah so the
the histogram could look similar to the
well calibrated one it could not there's
generally under confident
um underconfident models will have more
probabilities assigned near 0.5 so
you'll have you'll see a bulge over here
if they're under confident and you know
confident ones will have
more more assignments at the extremes
right
what you want ideally want are confident
models that are also calibrated
this question
yeah so the question is uh why not just
look at the calibration plot and just
ignore
uh the the histogram completely
and uh the the answer for that is back
in the calibration discussion we saw how
you know calibration does not
necessarily mean accuracy at all
right so you can have a perfectly
calibrated plot
but most of your assigned probabilities
might be you know just 0.5
and you have a few of them that are you
know well calibrated on the other side
but for most of them you're just
predicting 0.5
and that's that's kind of bad so ideally
you want a plot
that is perfectly calibrated and also
well separated and have these two peaks
so that's that's like a good sign
right so the brightest score is
basically the the mean squared error
between the predicted
probability right so this y is
either 0 or 1 and this
is between 0 and 1.
so we see that even though the
the usual ranking based metrics are
exactly the same
the brighter score between them is quite
different
right and the brighter score
is also a proper scoring rule
so in in the in the example one of you
asked before about you know
what if you are in a in a kind of a
finance kind of a scenario where you
want to
um when you want to to
you know be more risky in some way for
example
you know you can use you know the
brighter scoring rule in those cases you
know the briar scoring rule
also is also a proper scoring rule
which means it will value calibrated
probabilities more but it is more you
know
risk tolerant it has other tradeoffs
compared to
the log loss
right any questions in this
right so so basically the takeaway is
that you know always look at the
calibration and the
histogram in conjunction make sure first
make sure that the model is well
calibrated
otherwise your predictions are not even
they're not even
valid probabilities and once it's
calibrated
look at you know look at look at uh how
well separated they are
so the the the you may also see
the terminologies like calibration
versus
discrimination
right so discrimination generally refers
to how well your model can separate
positives and negatives in a ranking
sense
and calibration tells you how meaningful
are the assigned probability values
right and and you you generally want
your model to be
well calibrated and have high high
discrimination
right moving on
right so the the log probability of the
log loss
can also be used in unsupervised
learning so supposing you have a
gaussian mixture model or factor
analysis
right you can use log p of x to measure
your um whether your model has under fit
or lower
or over fit log p of x by itself the raw
value
is hard to interpret you know it's it's
hard to just look at
the log likelihood and tell whether the
model is good or bad
but you can always measure the log
likelihood or log p of x on your
training set and on your test set and
measure the difference between
them right if if the if the gap between
them is very large if you if you have a
high
log likelihood on your training set but
low likelihood on your test set
then your unsupervised learning model
has overfit on your training data
so you want you want to you know up so
so
under fitting overfitting uh even though
it's commonly
used in the supervised learning setting
um to to
measure accuracy or whatever is not
limited to supervised learning alone
right
under fitting or fitting concepts apply
just as well
to uh unsupervised uh settings as well
this question
oh so so uh so what you want to
uh so the way you want to uh so so the
question is
um you have a particular training value
and you have a particular test value how
do you kind of
find a balance between them the the
answer is very similar to how you would
do in a supervised setting let's say you
have
you know uh 85
accuracy on your training set
in the supervised classification let's
say you have you know 23 percent on your
test set
right so what do you do you go and you
know address bias or
address variance to bring the gap uh
closer together similarly
you know you fit a gaussian mixture
model that gives you a log likelihood on
your training data to be
you know generally they are like you
know you know like minus
two thousand um just like a reasonable
value for you know a log likelihood of a
gaussian mixture model
let's say you get minus two thousand on
your our training set and on your test
set
you get minus 18 000
right then then you you know it probably
means
you have assigned too many number of
clusters you want to reduce your k
value for example and kind of bring the
two together
um or something something along those
charts
okay so yeah so log p of x uh is
is uh is can be used as an evaluation
metric to measure
the gap between your training likelihood
and the test likelihood to see if your
unsupervised model has overfit or not
however you know k-means is a little
tricky you know k-means does not have a
good probabilistic interpretation
and it also uses you know fixed
covariances so with k means it's it's
a little harder to measure whether it's
under fit or overfit however so
however the gaussian mixture models it
probabilistic models in general it
um works pretty well
yes questions
so so uh you know can we take the mean
squared between
uh you know the centroids and uh the
examples
so which is basically the distortion
function and measure the distortion
function on the test set
uh you could do that but that does not
always work well so even the distortion
function can
can so for example let us say
you know you have
some some clusters like this
and let us say you assign
let's say you you you assign six
uh cluster center centroids so you get
one let me use a different color
so you get the centroid the centroid
centroid
centroid centroid centroid right
and i mean looking at just qualitatively
you can tell you kind of overfit there
are actually just three clusters but
you've assigned six
however if you were to measure the
distortion function if you were to hold
a fraction of them as a hold out set
and measure the measure the distortion
function on the test set
they will look kind of pretty similar so
the distortion function
um you know because it does not uh have
this
flexible covariance per cluster right
it's
it's it's hard to use the distortion
function as as
as a way to check whether you under fit
or overfit
if you can't if that is not a good
measure
yeah so you it's it's of the k means
it's it's usually
you you end up doing some kind of a
visualization and it's more
you know like you know see you know do
some spot checks to see if
you know a few examples that were in the
same cluster were meaningful or not
or you know if you know similar examples
ended up in different clusters you know
it's
there is there is no it's not as cleanly
defined as the log likelihood that you
get from
gaussian mixture models
this question
so the comment there was you can you can
have this you know
distortion versus k and
you know uh eventually it's gonna the
distortion is gonna
flatten out and you know maybe you know
just look at it and
and choose some value right um however
this
requires as i said you know this is like
a heuristic you have to look at it and
and decide you can't
compare one scalar value with another
scalar value one on a test set and one
on a training set and
and declare that you overfit right so
yeah so
measuring under fitting and overfitting
is is uh
is not as clean with k-means as it is
with gaussian mixture models
yeah but this this this is a commonly
used approach
right moving on to ah class imbalance
problems
so generally if you have um examples
where one class is
is a much smaller fraction than the
other or you know
if one class kind of dominates the other
class then you know
you kind of call it um you say that
you're in a class imbalance scenario
and a lot of the metrics that we've uh
kind of seen
um uh uh today can end up
uh breaking down in under class and
balance scenarios
right so um
so for example accuracy right so if you
are if you are in
in in a class imbalance scenario and
let's say you have just one percent of
all your examples to be
you know a positive um and you just
uh you have this this blind classifier
that predicts no all the time
it gets 99 accuracy right so having a
high accuracy
does not mean much uh in in a class
imbalance scenario similarly the log
loss
right in the log loss um the majority
class can easily dominate the assigned
probabilities so if you have
if your
log loss can be easily um
so imagine a logistic regression where
you have some you know some some number
of positive examples over here
um and you have just one negative
example over here
right logistic regression will place the
separating hyperplane that is the line
at which
the the uh y hat is 0.5 probably
somewhere over here
right and and um
so so the the majority class can easily
dominate
the log loss and make the um
make the uh separating hyper plane be
placed at some kind of an unreasonable
unreasonable location right so the log
loss is also vulnerable to
um class imbalance auroc
right so imagine let's see how the auroc
can break down
right so let us say you have
examples that that are ranked like this
right so suppose you are you are
[Music]
suppose you are um in a in a
fraud detection scenario credit card
fraud detection right
you want to build a classifier given a
credit card transaction classified
classify it as fraudulent or not right
in this scenario let's say you decide to
use auroc
as your metric right auroc
uh and and let's say the the uh
so typically in in these kind of
scenarios where
uh the prevalence is very low most of
the times
you are in this kind of a retrieval
scenario or information retrieval kind
of a scenario
where you want to uh you know in this
given this pool off
of all credit card transactions you just
want to surface the fraudulent ones to
the top
and you know act on them somehow right
so in in this kind of a scenario let's
say
you you have a model that let's say you
have you know 10 000 transactions
and in this 10 000 transactions let's
say
10 of them are fraudulent
right and let us say
1 2 3 4 4 5 6 7 8
9 10. so the first 10 were all
good transactions and the next 10 were
all fraudulent
right assume there are 10 here and then
you have all the good examples
so this is the first 10
next 10 and the remaining 9980
right let us say your your model ranks
them in this way
right from uh you know from
from the user of this model
this is a useless model because you want
to act on the top most likely
fraudulent uh uh mo the
the top ten most likely transactions are
to be fraudulent
but all of them over here were valid
ones
right and then comes the fraudulents uh
you know after
uh you know you have an equal number of
you know good transactions and then you
have the rest right
now what's going to be the auc of this
model
right let's let's uh do a quick uh
sanity check so
so uh we have uh 10 positives so chop
this into 10
[Music]
10 intervals the sensitivity side and
the specificity side
chop it into 9990
right you have 9990
pieces here so the first 10 were all
negatives which means
you know for the first 10 you get a
steep drop
and then we have 10 all the 10 positive
examples so you know 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
and then you get a negative and this
will give you an area under the curve of
you know 0.999 or whatever 0.99
uh maybe i missed 0.99 or 99.
anyway it doesn't matter it gives you a
really high auc even though
you know from from the usefulness of
this model
you got only good transactions flagged
as as fraudulent at the top
right so in class imbalance scenarios
auc can also be
pretty bad you know accuracy is the
worst you know you probably never should
use accuracy when you have class
imbalance
but auc can also be can also be fooled
right and so au prc is somewhat more
robust
in precision reco in in in these kind of
scenarios when you are interested
in you know um the quality at the top
where your focus is on the top uh of
what you do because
you know you're generally not going to
act on the rest at all you're just going
to
do something with you know the the top
predicted examples
in in those kind of scenarios you
probably want to use au prc rather than
auroc
so uh so so so the summary is that where
in in
um class imbalance scenarios your least
preference should be accuracy as the
choice of metric
aurac might be better might not be
better uh because aurc can also be
fooled
auprc is generally more robust uh but
with au prc there are
you know other challenges that come with
it for example
you know if your au prc curve looks you
know jagged like this
this is pretty sensitive to uh
you know the ordering over here if your
ordering is is uh
different it might look very different
right
so the auroc can sometimes be pretty
sensitive to small changes
yeah so the so the question is uh you
know
um can you can you kind of
adjust the class balance by up sampling
or down sampling
the classes to fit your model you can
you can do such things
so that's that's actually a very good
point if you
in order to make your model perform
better you can do all kinds of things
like adjusting the class balance
up sampling the you know the minority
class down sampling the majority class
and so on however when you are
measuring the quality of your model on a
test set
or a validation set the prevalence in
the test set or the validation
set should match the true prevalence
right do the adjustment of sampling down
sampling only on the training set and
not on the
on the test side
it could help it's you know the question
of whether uh you know up sampling and
down sampling will it help or not
the answer is always cross-validate and
check right have have a validation set
which you know which is which is kind of
you know pure in the sense it
it has the same prevalence ratios and so
on um
do whatever you want with the with the
training set up sample it down sampling
whatever but then measure it on this
you know pure validation set which has
the right uh or the true uh prevalence
ratio and see if it helped out
yeah generally auprc is is um that
there are a few more metrics uh i think
in the next slide
um in the next slide so probably the
slide after we will
uh we look at them right so you can
extend all of these to the
multi-class classification setting as
well so
the confusion matrix in a multi-class
will be uh you know
k by k or n by n depending on the number
of classes you have
so in binary it was just you know
the confusion matrix are just four where
you know you had two classes
two classes but if
you're not in a multi-class setting you
can have
one row per predicted class
and one column per actual class
right and then you just count you know
what what what number of
you know class c did you predict a c and
and so on
and here you want your diagonals to be
heavy
right and the reason why uh
you know the name confusion matrix is
used is
probably more illuminating here because
if you have
high you know high
high values over here then it means the
model is generally confusing
you know class b to class d right so
uh you know the model is confused
between those two classes you know
that's that's an interpretation you can
uh you can use
right so uh some of the other metrics
like accuracy can be
a accept accuracy can be
analyzed as one versus many which means
you can you can plot
uh au prc curve for one class
right you you know but take all the all
the
predicted probabilities see what
probability was assigned to this class
versus others you know just just
condense your classes into just two you
can do that
accuracy you can however you know get
get it's basically the
sum of all the diagonals divided by the
sum of all all the
elements there are variants of
the uh roc and the prc curve um
where there's a smile a minor d take
called micro averaging and
macro averaging and you can extend the
roc curves and the precision recall
curves to
multi-class setting uh
and you can also there's something
called a cost sensitive
learning techniques where you can assign
some kind of a dollar value to each
um each
cell in the confusion matrix and you can
construct a loss function
by um
so uh you can you can construct loss
functions by by uh
absorbing these dollar values or any
kind of a weight
into the loss function and and train on
them so you can you can look up
uh cost sensitive learning for
techniques to do that
right if if if the cost of
a false positive is a lot more than a
cost negative then you can
incorporate those kind of prior
information into your loss function
right and finally some ah some some
tips on choosing a evaluation matrix
so you will see that commonly you know
the problem that you're trying to solve
generally fits into a few templates or a
few patterns
right so there are going to be some
problems where
high precision is a hard constraint and
you want to maximize the recall
as much as possible subject to this high
precision
so one way to one one example for that
would be if
um the action that you're going to take
on positive
examples or examples that are predicted
to be
a positive can have a severe
negative effect or side effect on
a on if the example happened to be
negative then you want to have high
precision as a hard constraint which
means you want to
your model when it says positive it has
to be positive and
subject to that hard constraint you want
to improve your recall as much as
possible
right and um for example you know um
search engine results right when you
when you search for
something on let's say google right
what's going to show up on the top
it better be relative it better be you
know correct
you may miss out a few search results
but showing irrelevant
irrelevant results on the top is is
really really bad
as opposed to missing out some relevant
results
in those cases high precision is is is
is a hard constraint and you want to
recall as
you want to improve your recall subject
to this constraint
similarly if you're writing a grammar
correction software then
you know if you miss out a few
corrections that is fine but making a
bad suggestion is a lot lot worse
and in those cases you want the metric
that you want to use
might not be any one of the metric but
you know um
the metric could be recall at a certain
precision which means
you have you know a precision recall
curve that looks like this
you fix your your uh
you fix your precision level to be some
acceptable
threshold and you measure
what the recall was at that
fixed precision level and then you want
to optimize your recall
right so this length will now be your
metric
right the recall at some fixed precision
on the other hand you can have other
kinds of problems for example medical
diagnostics
where you want to to um let's say you
have some kind of a screening test
where let's say it's a blood test and if
it's you know if it's positive then you
want to
send them to a more expensive more
accurate test
you know and so let's say you are you
need to build some kind of a
a simple simple screening test and in
those cases
it would be very bad if you missed
patients who actually had a condition
in which case false negatives are a lot
worse
but it's okay to have a few false
positives because you're going to
conduct this more expensive test anyways
on those
whom you flag in those kind of scenarios
you want to maximize your precision
subject to a high recall right you don't
want to lose out um
patients who have a condition in the
screening test right but at the same
time
you know um subject to this you know 100
recall constraint
you still want to improve your precision
because you don't want
you i mean you don't want to waste the
more expensive test on people who may
not have the condition
so in those cases you may want to have a
fixed recall
right fix the recall and maximize
the precision right in that case this
height will be the metric that you care
about
right so you can you can you can ah
construct these derived metrics
from the precision recall curve
depending on what's what's important for
your application
and sometimes there may be capacity
constraint right let's say you want
you want to um you want
among the patients that are admitted
today in the hospital let's say
you want to take some kind of you know a
different action on
say five of them because you have only
five doctors available to
say test this new procedure for example
in those case k is a heart constraint
your capacity is a hard constraint
right in in those cases all what matters
is the quality of the top k results
right you want you want high precision
in the top k you don't really care
what happened here right because you
have this hard capacity constraint
even if you're losing out other
positives you don't you don't care
because
anyway you did not have the capacity to
do anything about them right
and in those cases just look at the
precision in the top k
so rank your examples just look at the
top k ranks and see what the precision
was in
in in in that fraction and there are
many you know
similar to this there are many other
derived derived metrics that something
that
you should think about and decide what
meaningful metric what what a metric is
meaningful for
the application that you are doing
right and similarly um you know to to
choose
choose choose a threshold um you're
going to use a
you know the threshold that you choose
for classification would also be
based on this supposing you have a fixed
um
fixed recall you you want a fixed recall
of certain level
you know go up to the curve and and work
work backwards and see what the
threshold was that got you this point
all right that's that's about it from ah
for the evaluation metrics
ah we'll wrap up with that any other
questions
with what we've seen so far
um if not i'll i'll be around here you
know walk up and you know ask any
questions you have
and and that's it for today we'll break
you